anyways my point is do you think that
women should compete for a man
absolutely
definitely with a prize
we're the ones who control marriage we
control Legacy like
we do all the hard work essentially in
terms of infrastructure so why wouldn't
you compete for us it doesn't make any
sense even if he's got a girl even if
yeah of course that's that's the real
company like you when you think about it
to like a point where you know
our communities were married a lot more
like you know I'm saying like the
marriage rate was a lot higher
the competition was even more steep
that's why they made songs like Rolling
Stones and this is what what he's
basically saying which is true which is
like modern women don't really have game
this is why they're struggling to keep a
man because getting a man's attention is
easy
a fast car could drive past and men
would be like oh did you see that it's
getting our attention is easy but
keeping our attention is where I feel
you know people have lost that respect
and that's why we don't get treated like
a prize because you feel like we're not
the prize until
you become a side chick and you realize
there is actually a prize
what about you guys
would you compete for a man no no
absolutely no no why why should I why
shouldn't he compete for me why am I
competing against another girl if I'm
not good enough then he doesn't deserve
me if if he's comparing me against
against another woman saying oh you know
her her qualities and traits might be
better why
like if I'm not good enough then you
don't deserve me you don't think that
you compare him to other men yeah but
then I'm not asking him to compete as in
if if the man is in the lineup he would
be the that man that I would then go and
see like women don't have
sidemen or whatever so
that's not true we would definitely have
what did you just say I definitely do
um
you have go around the corner guys as
well
women don't have sidemen Jesus so how
does a five foot do you compete with a
six foot dude well they don't
there's no competition
as in if I was looking I wouldn't look
at the five foot two though I would look
at the six foot what makes you think
that the six foot dude is looking at you
well you just know how
but you don't you don't think okay so so
if it's a guy that you're attracted to
like how you don't meet guys that you're
really into often right yes like it's
it's probably rare for you when you find
a guy that you're really really into
yeah right yeah so you find him and if
you're really really into him other
women are probably really really into
him right that's how it goes right yeah
so it's like if he's talking to five
girls and they're they're let's say
within a point pretty right they're all
up like within a point
how does he pick
s the best one okay so how would you
show if you're applying for a job
like wouldn't you compete for that job
and get the right skills for it I would
I think compete is the wrong word though
I wouldn't relationships are not a job
yeah it's not your same as do you think
don't you think men are competing
for the women that we want no no way no
you're not we don't compete from the
what you've said you think that women
just come to you and you've got them and
yeah for me but I'm an exception to the
rule okay because I already know that
there's a school like like the dude just
said there's a small percentage of men
that are smashing everything
[Music]
I know the 90 of dudes that not that are
at work every day that are completely
invisible
so when I hear people say certain things
I'm like
you've never heard of a nerd having more
than one baby mother
is to do that's in jail serving 20 years
that's got five baby mums why because
women like the same dude so that same
six foot guy that's in the room that
you're saying that you wouldn't compete
for maybe you might not compete with
your friends but if it's random girls in
there you're gonna compete and you're
gonna do what women do which is try and
be in his line of sight you know how to
compete
I think compete is the wrong word though
you would you would just be yourself
like and and you know what you bring to
the table like I know that when I meet a
guy I know exactly what I'm bringing to
the table do you not think that I
eyelashes eyebrows and Antarctic tan and
hair colors and hair lamps and all these
things that you're not think on your net
all of these things are competing these
are these are definitely competing no
way so why do girls spend money on their
lips if they're not competing what's
what's what's it for yourself because
it's for a while fashion good yeah I
feel better feel better than dick
laughs
no all right so it's for us you don't
try to look good for men
you don't try to like because if I if
I'm going out somewhere and I know
there's going to be attractive guys
there I'm going to try to look better
but I guess that's the same whether I'm
single or in a relationship so if I'm in
a relationship I'll still dress up and
do my hair and that's because I want to
be put together it's not for guys to
move to me I agree I don't agree with
that because as soon as you get in a
relationship with a girl it goes from
supermodel to
you've never tried to dress up for a
date like you're going on a date with
guy and you want to impress him you want
to look good of course I just I dress
how I would dress I don't
think extra outside of how I would think
like girls anywhere yeah this is why the
same way I get up in the morning and I
want to be presentable for work it's not
I'm not trying to attract guys when I go
to work do you know what are you
changing your appearance for why why tan
to three four different Shades Darker
for what are you trying to write that's
an individual thing isn't it no but I'm
just asking what is so if it's not a
competition why are we trying to get up
in a ladder or something I'm just asking
a general question I think I think
compete is actually the right word
because you in order to get anywhere in
life you need to you need to go like go
up against somebody to get what you want
so if it's something that you actually
want why would you not
um
there's there's loads of things and
you're in your mind there's loads of
things that you do to go and go for what
you want so whether that is from a
woman's perspective whether that is
putting on uh the right even perfume or
the right lipstick or the right because
you know that right listen I'm gonna do
my best because this guy right here I
want this guy do you know what I mean so
that is a it's a competition because
you're trying to beat all the other
girls out there because there's going to
be loads of you're competing with the
guys with the um with the girls that are
around the guy that you want I mean I
just think like pretty is common and so
I feel like you have to have something
that makes yourself stand out to a guy
it's like fishing yeah and so it's like
if if I if I if I'm seeing a guy and I
find out his favorite meal I'm gonna
learn how to cook it because I I want
him to talk to me and give me attention
rather than the other girls that is
competing that's yeah
you don't do that that's not gay because
this is what I was saying earlier modern
women don't have a game why wouldn't you
do that
what I'm saying is if I'm with someone
if I if I'm cooking for someone I'm
already with them I'm not competing with
other girls that they're talking to uh
you see but but that's what you got
wrong
because I've had relationships so I
don't have to compete for relationships
someone if a guy comes to me and wants
to be with me then we're together I
think I think I think I've not had
experiences where I have to go in out
and I'm seeing someone and I'm like he's
good looking and there's loads of girls
that like him so I need to do extra
things to get him yes I don't do that
okay maybe maybe not you but I think
that that is exactly where a lot of
women go wrong because absolutely
because they don't even when they jump
into a relationship they they stop
competing
when normally if if it's a if it's a guy
if if they jump into a relationship
um then they're gonna they're gonna try
and
um
how they compete for you is to make
themselves better
follow their purpose you know
uh build up their status build up their
money you know I mean that's how they
compete for for you and maybe others
whatever but if if a woman's not gonna
do not not they don't need to do the
same but if they're not gonna try and
compete even when in a relationship and
that's what that's yeah that's where it
starts compete with who everybody else
everyone else that's around that's
around when you guys were when you guys
but with the word compete
that I don't do things for my partner
yeah or I didn't say that I'm just not
company I'm not in my head going I need
to cook him dinner because someone else
will I need to dress nice because
someone else is
can I ask you a question
it's not about someone else it's just
like young people you don't you don't
wait wait you don't want a guy that's
worth competing for that's why like I
don't want a guy that no one else wants
there has to be other people involved
but everyone every time you walk outside
there is at your at your man's job
there's gonna be four or five girls that
are like they know full well he's in a
relationship but they will take him and
I'm aware of that they'll take him it
doesn't bother me
it's more nuanced than that though like
you're competing in a sense where you
look after him and you make sure he's
good but if you started to neglect him
and you didn't do all the things that
you do then he might start looking
elsewhere yeah but what is it
I think I think the work compete is
triggering you too much to actually like
understand
yeah when a man and a woman get in a
relationship and everyone's talking
about what the woman should do to keep
the man but what is them what is the man
gonna do it
do you guys do you guys usually pay for
dates
uh equal split on the first day I would
say the man should pay but after that we
can go halves or split the bill I'm I'm
happy to do that do you expect a man if
you were attacked and you were with him
do you expect him to protect you
or would you just say oh you deal with
this on your own you got it uh she got a
black belt
[Music]
he's gonna be like you've got this you
got this yeah
how would you respond would you want to
stay with him
no no right why not
well because because men provide
protection that's why that's that's
right protection provision and
profession but he also needs to maintain
lots of things as well as a woman does
when they get into relationships no
women don't have to do nothing when you
get in a relationship that's why you get
into relationships
what do you actually have to physically
do other than keep my knees satisfied in
a relationship let's cut away you what
you're doing actually in your own life
so let's draw two circles and the two
circles that interact that is where
relationship's supposed to live that's
how you last in one the other the
outsides of a circle are supposed to be
in your own lives those little sections
there what are you supposed to what are
you doing
in my own Circle no no not in your own
Circle in the middle so in the circle
that crosses with the person that you
remember relationship so you'll be
cooking him dinner
um I don't know doing his washing
deciding dates and arranging things and
I don't know a lot and would you want to
pay for anything
you're expecting that you don't pay for
nothing no no the stuff that you pay for
should be be buying me gifts and buying
a family gifts that's the stuff that you
should be paying for right
that's what you'd want your money to be
spent on
I think that a man and woman can go
equal as in if we're going on a date or
or we're going out to a restaurant for
dinner it can be split in half it can be
I can I'm not expecting you to to pay
therefore I think that I'm still doing
my stuff you can do your stuff it's just
not about protection it's about lots of
things yeah but
we're not saying what you can do I could
put on a jump a parachute and jump off
this this Penthouse right now I could do
that but that wouldn't make any sense
what would make sense is me getting an
elevator what makes sense is the man
paying for it because you are in a
relationship that's why you're the first
thing you said was cooking food your
innate brain was to go straight to the
kitchen and if I was to say to you go
straight to the kitchen you might kick
me because you're a black belt if I was
to say it but your DNA was like food
provision home because that is
that is the natural order of things like
so what man or woman's supposed to do
will protect it's like I said you don't
you don't see nobody fighting for women
to go and fight in Ukraine when they
sent them all here
it's the men over there fighting where
where is the people protesting for the
women to stay in the Army and fight the
Russian men
it's quiet women only want equality
when it comes they don't want equality
when it comes to relationships they want
to Quality everywhere else but in terms
of relationships we want to keep it
traditional so you have to kind of pick
a side but I still think that men and
women both have to come
maintain the relationship together a man
still got to put in just as much as
effort as a woman I I agree I agree with
that I think I I think I think I said
that earlier like a man has to compete
me we compete daily I think we day in
day out we can please show me the number
one of the number one causes of divorce
is financial women tend to leave um 70
to 80 percent of the time 90 of she's
college educated so I might have to
compete every day in the workforce to to
keep us one of the number one indicators
that a man is going to get divorced is
that his woman out earns him
so it's like if they don't make enough
money we leave statistically
they went on someone as many of you know
I was just banned on Tick Tock and we
are demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible